Today we learn about the difference
between warranties and conditions.
Proceeded in a contract by examining the
case of in Ray Carter's claim decided
by the Supreme Court of Pennsylvania
1957 Carter's claim touches on many
concepts at the heart of important
modern contracts such as the concept of
material adverse changes
for merger agreements,
a promise. He has two ways to
protect herself in a contract.
Warranty protection and
condition protection.
Nonperformance of a warranty gives
rise to breach of contract damages.
Non Occurrence of condition allows a
prophecy to suspend its own performance.
Failure of a condition of Ford's,
a defensive weapon and excuse but
does not give an offensive weapon.
A claim for breach of
contract phrase differently.
A condition protection allows the privacy
to get out of his or her own promises,
whereas a warranty protection allows
the primacy to actively sue for damages.
Some of just described a condition
proceeding as a shield but not as sword.
It gives rise to only a
defense and protection and
the ability to withhold your
own performance can at times provide
stronger protections than the ability to
sue for damages.
Defensive protections can work.
Forfeitures when the other side is already
relied and defense protections don't
require the hassle of going to
court and winning a judgment.
Plaintiff, the plaintiff,
the buyer and appellant, uh,
Lester l Carden entered into a 25
page written contract to purchase a
Pennsylvania Corporation and five of
its subsidiaries including the defendant
appellee Edwin Jay shuttle company about
$187,000 of the purchase price was put
in escrow to indemnify the plaintiff
buyer against liabilities specified in the
agreement as we studied before and
send tronics versus Gen income.
Asgrows involve and arrangement where
part of the purchase price is held by a
third party to compensate the buyer
with effectively a reduced price if the
seller's assets turn out to
be worth less than expected
in the contract listed under the heading
of conditions proceeded was a term
paragraph nine that said the financial
condition of the defendant company shall
be no less favorable
at the time of closing.
Then on June 30th of 1954 which was
probably when the book's closed at the end
of the last financial year.
As you know,
the closing date refers to when the
sale actually occurs with title to the
assets transferring to the new buyer.
The plaintiff claimed that the financial
condition was less favorable at closing
and refused and requested
approximately $70,000 from the escrow.
The parties submitted this to arbitration.
The arbitrator awarded
$3,182 to the plaintiff.
Plaintiffs appealed to the court of
common pleas was denied and the instinct
court affirmed.
The main issue is whether the financial
condition in this case was actually a
warranty such that plaintiff
is entitled to damages.
The court held the agreement was
carefully drafted and is clear that the
provision in question is not a
warranty but a condition proceeded.
As such,
plaintiff had the right to refuse to
purchase because of the failure of this
condition, but that option to refuse
had to be made by the closing date.
By accepting seller's performance
and going ahead with the closing,
plaintiff waived its right
under the condition proceeding.
The court explain the result in terms
of the plain meaning of the contract.
In this case,
the contract had the classic structure
distinguishing between two clearly
demarcated sets of provisions.
On the one hand there were representations
and warranties and on the other hand
there were conditions. The structure
is found in most corporate contracts.
A Re a result explained in terms of
plain meaning is justified where the
agreement has been drafted with
particular clarity and the other party has
failed to introduce evidence that the
words used are reasonably susceptible to
another meaning the buyer waived the
express conditioned by electing to go
forward with the purchase
at the closing date.
The agreement also contained a provision
Paragraph 5g concerning value in the
representation and warranty section in
which the seller represented that between
June 30th and September 17th,
1954 there had not been any change
in companies or its subsidiaries,
financial condition,
assets,
liability or businesses other than changes
in the ordinary course of business,
none of which has been materially adverse.
The buyer warranted that
this representation was true.
How was the scope of this warranty
different than the scope of the condition
concerning value?
Well,
the warranty or promise of value was
limited to changes in materially,
uh,
that were material adverse quote other
than in the ordinary course of business
unquote.
So reductions in value from the ordinary
course of business would not constitute
a breach of the warranty,
but would be a failure of the condition
that the financial condition of the
company shall be no less favorable.
Reductions in value from the ordinary
course of the business would accordingly
give the buyer an option not
to buy at the closing date,
but not the right to sue for breach of
warranty damages after the closing date,
however,
things change and the buyer,
if she chooses to close his left solely
with the offensive remedy of suing for
breach under the limited warranty,
why would the parties write a contract
giving the buyer broader defensive
protections than authentic protections?
Well,
the parties might have x,
uh,
expanded the scope of the warranty to
allow breach of contract actions for any
reduction in value or they might have
decreased the scope of the condition for
only reductions outside of the
ordinary course of business.
Either of these changes would have
rendered the offensive and defensive
protections congruent,
making them both conditions
and warranty protections.
The parties might have chosen.
However,
for asymmetric protections to constrain
various types of buyer and seller
opportunism,
the parties might have realized that it
was going to be hard to prove to a court
whether the company experienced
a reduction in value.
The contract give the gave the
buyers abroad right not to buy,
but only allows the
buyers to sue for damages.
If the seller does something outside
of the ordinary course of business that
hurts the firm value.
So if a seller starts liquidating the
equipment that's outside the ordinary
course of business and the buyer can
bring suit for a reduction in value from
that stripping of of equipment.
But the ta contract gives the seller
strong incentive incentives not to do
anything outside the ordinary course
of business so as to limit the buyers
offensive rights instead,
the contract in effect says if the
company's overall financial condition has
worsened,
then don't buy it if you don't want to.
But if you still want the company,
don't try to sue for damages.
This form of asymmetric protection
strikes a balance between two types of
opportunism. You don't want the seller
to run the company into the ground,
but you don't want to allow the buyer
to hold up the sale at the last minute.
Although this case is over 50 years old,
the warranty conditions strategy is still
employed to allegate risk between the
date of contract and the date
of the closing. In particular,
buyers and sellers are worried about
negative changes in the value of what's
being exchanged between the contract
date and before. The closing.
The warranty only changes in values
that do not come from ordinary course of
business.
Condition covers changes from any cause.
The contractual regulation of material
adverse changes at the heart of in Ray
Carter's claim,
it has become one of the most hotly
negotiated in and litigated questions of
merger law.
Most friendly merger agreements contain
material adverse change clauses.
These are called Mac clauses or sometimes
material adverse effect may clauses
which make the buyers duty to by
conditional on there not being a material
adverse change in the seller's
financial condition. In recent years,
merger agreements tend to include the
traditional standard Mac or may terms,
but also explicitly negotiated carve outs
that limit the buyer's ability to exit
the Mac and may provisions in gender
substantial litigation because it's hard
for litigants to predict
whether a particular negative
event will be considered
after the fact by a court
as materially adverse.
Sometimes contractual provisions are
unclear whether they are creating promises
or conditions.
It's an interpretation issue where if
in doubt the common law's preferences to
interpret ambiguous
provisions merely as promises,
giving the promise, see a,
uh, an affirmative offensive,
right to sue for damages,
but not the defensive right to
withhold your own performance.
This is because of failure of a provision
can have a condition of a condition
can produce inequitable forfeitures where
one side refuses to perform after the
other side has substantially relied.
For example,
some contracts might include a provision
saying buyer shall notify seller of the
place of delivery two weeks in
advance of the ship and date.
Is this provision a buyer promise giving
rise to a breach of contract action if
the notice is late or is it a condition
relieving seller of the duty to ship if
the buyer is a second late or is it
both the promise and it condition?
In one case,
a buyer who had contracted to buy rice
failed by 12 hours to give seller two
weeks notice because of the
price of rice was rising,
the seller treated the provision as
a condition and refuse to perform.
Courts will tend to treat
ambiguous provisions as a
promise and give the seller
instead of breach of contract remedy
and not as a condition unless the
contractual provision is more
clearly conditional and its language.
This preference for interpretation
in favor of promises. However,
it does not apply to contracts quote
of a type under which only the Aba Gore
generally undertakes duties unquote.
That's a quote from the restatement.
Second Section two 27 insurance
is regarded as a contract
of this type where the
usual interpretation is that the insured
has no enforceable duty to pay premiums
rather if the,
the risk the insurer if the
risk insured against occurs,
the insurance company's duty to pay under
the policy is merely conditioned upon
the,
uh,
earlier payment of premiums unless special
arrangements with third parties have
been made.
However,
the insured's failure to pay a premium
is a failure of a condition rather than a
breach of contract phrase differently.
The insured's promise to pay the premium
is treated as a condition precedent to
the insurer's duty to provide coverage.
Insurance is an odd kind of contract
where the insurers right to a premium is
solely protected by the defensive right
of the insurer to withhold performance
with no insurer offensive,
right to sue for a buyer's breach.
Stepping back,
we can see that promises,
promises right to a promise or his
performance is protected and starkly
different ways and insurers,
right to insurance premiums that
protected solely by defensive writes.
The buyers right in Carter was protected
before closing with larger defensive
rights than offensive rights.
But in Jacob and young versus Ken,
we learned that the substantial
performance rule protects
the buyer's right to
Redding price with broader offensive
rights than defensive rights.
Because if you remember,
in that case,
the buyer could sue offensively
for breach of promise,
but was not allowed to withhold
her own performance. In summary,
there are two ways for a promise
see to be protected in a contract.
Warranty protection gives rise to damages
and condition protection gives rise,
gives rise to a defense or protection.
The right to stop one zone performance.
In determining whether an event is
a warranty or condition proceedings,
courts will usually rely on the
plain meaning of the contract.
If the agreement is ambiguous,
the interpretation favors promises
instead of conditions in the interest of
avoiding forfeiture.